>>Female Introducer: Hi everyone. Welcome.
On behalf of the Authors@Google program, I
am excited to welcome back Mary Roach. As
one of you put is, Mary is one of the funniest
and most madcap of science writers. She is
of the firm belief that there is no question
to goofy to ask, or boring to Google. Her
previous books include: "Stiff: The Curious
Lives of Human Cadavers," "Spook: Science
Tackles the Afterlife" and "Bonk: The Curious
Coupling of Science and Sex." Her newest book
is "Packing for Mars: The Curious Science
of Life in the Void."
Now Mary probably had aspirations of becoming
an astronaut, but Mary has done us the courtesy
of researching all things that our eight-year-old
selves forgot to think of like, how you keep
clean up in space? Showers don't work without
gravity. What do you eat? Mom's Rice Krispy
treats probably won't meet NASA's nutrition
standards. And most importantly, where do
you go to the bathroom? Toilets don't work
in zero G either. Lucky for us the book goes
into extreme detail.
[Laughter]
About these questions and more, here to tell
us more, please welcome Mary Roach.
[Applause]
>>Mary Roach: Thank you. This is my Tang substitute.
[laughter] On my book tour I actually, my
publicist thought it would be a great idea
to have Tang in the bookstores for everybody
so I would dutifully drink Tang until I realized
my kidneys were starting probably to fluoresce.
[Laughter]
Tang. I always start by telling people, Tang
is not a NASA invention. Actually I'm gonna
use this guy. Ooh, it's got a cord. This is
very old school--I like this. Can everybody
hear OK? Is this even turned on? Is it turned
on, right? OK. I feel like Merv Griffin.
[Laughter]
No, anyway. But Tang, Tang is not an invention
of NASA. NASA just would order it from the
store, like anybody else. Is it called a commercial
off-the-shelf product, COTS product, and NASA
actually does a lot of purchasing of COTS,
commercial off-the-shelf products, including
the diapers that they wear in the big, puffy
space walking suits when they go to repair
to the solar panel or whatever, they are wearing
an adult diaper. And I don't know what they
are using now, but for a period of time, this
is true, the public affairs office told me
this--it was a brand called Rejoice.
[Laughter]
Just like the most optimistic name for an
adult diaper that you can imagine. Anyway,
so, my book is a book about space and astronauts,
but not really a typical book about space
and astronauts. I don't know if there necessarily
a typical, but there's a lot of sort of heroics
and bravely going and coming back. And you
have Jim Lovell and Apollo 13 fighting, his
crew and him fighting for their lives and
the way of the moon, explosion, all of that.
It's not that kind of book. I did talk to
Captain Lovell, but not about Apollo 13, I
talked to him about Gemini 7. Gemini 7 was
fascinating to me because it was the longest
mission to date. It was a two-week mission.
It was the first time people had been in space
for that long. Before that it had been a few
days and part of what they were trying to
figure out, at that point, was, is two weeks
in a spacesuit, in a cramped space, without
a bathroom, without a shower, it is just too
horrible for a human being? It is too much
to stand? It is too awful? Do you get too
disgusting? So, that's actually what they
were looking into, and I did, you know, you
can look through the transcript, the mission
transcript, for all of the missions that NASA's
done. There are those big huge PDF files that
you can read, and there's a moment at Gemini,
Gemini 7, where the flight surgeon comes on
the radio, because there is a lot of information
back and forth, it's a medical mission essentially.
And the flight surgeon comes on the line and
he is talking to Commander Borman, who is
the other, there are two of them in the capsule.
He is like, exact words were, "Gemini 7, this
is the flight surgeon. Have you had any dandruff
problems up there, Frank?" I mean, this to
me is, the word "dandruff" in a mission transcript,
in an official NASA mission transcript, I
don't know why this just delighted me. And
further on the word "lotion." There are like
two grown men, orbiting earth, discussing
skin care. Commander Borman, Frank Borman,
was sort of difficult guy, and after a while
he stopped answering all questions about personal
products and skin care. It was like compromising
the overall manliness of the mission.
[Laughter]
But you kind of, you did have to feel bad
for them because this is zero gravity and
if you do have dandruff, it's not going to
fall to your shoulders, it's not going to
fall to the floor. It kind of hovers and I
actually asked Jim Lovell. I got Jim Lovell
to call me back, I think because everyone
wants to talk about Apollo 13 and nobody never
asks him about Gemini 7. So, you know, we
got on the phone and I said, "So was it just
likes a snow globe in there?"
[Laughter]
He said, "Mary you are investigating a rather
and usual aspect, a space flight."
[Laughter]
Anyway, so, I wanted, you know, the book is
about astronauts, it's about life in space,
but it's also about space on earth because
I found out that, because space is this really,
extreme, hostile, unusual, expensive place
where nothing that works down here works the
same as it does up there. And you need to
test it, and you need to kind of test it in
zero gravity if possible, and that is a little
tricky to do. You have to essentially put
it on one of these planes that kind of flies
like this. So anyway, but they do, they test
everything. They test even the toilets. OK,
now toilets, some people take gravity a little
bit for granted, I think. You kind of think
about water system. You know, there's the
sewage and the water and you don't realize
gravity plays a big role here because what
you have is, you have a growing mass, OK,
that's being extruded and with more mass you
have greater gravitation, and at a certain
point the material breaks free and falls down
into the toilet where it's whisked away and
everybody is happy. Well, in zero gravity
this doesn't happen, it just kind of hovers.
And, so, the zero gravity toilet has to give
you what they call, NASA Waste Management
people call "Good Separation." This is the
Holy Grail of the waste management engineer
at NASA. Good separation. So the toilet now
has to provide that separation and the way
it does it is by air flow. It sort of entrains
the bolas. I've got a lot of euphemisms out
of that. My time with the NASA Waste Management
Department. So you didn't train the bolas?
Well you have airflow doing that. It's basically
like sitting on a Shop-Vac. I was gonna say
shitting on a Sop Vac. [Laughter] Like sitting
on a Shop Vac, or shitting in a Sop Vac. Really,
either. OK, how much air flow, though? You
need to know, because if you have got too
much air flow you, all suction, you could
have some serious, uncomfortable-ness. Basically,
you got to test it, so you have to hold the
entire toilet over to Ellington Field and
get it on one of those planes, that does the,
C9, like this, and as the plane goes over
and down into a dive you have about 22 seconds
of zero gravity. OK, now, think about that.
[Laughter]
You are testing your toilet. This means, some
poor schmo from the Waste Management Systems
Department has 22 seconds in which to perform.
And I was never on, sadly, on one of these
flights, but I did talked to someone who had
been on boarded, it was Charles Borland, and
he is the guy who designed a lot of the food
systems that they use during Apollo and even
through Shuttle. And Charles Borland was there,
he had like 22 different food system packaging,
various things he was testing to make sure
it would work, and he said: "You know, they
had the toilet people, they had a curtain
that they pulled, but you could see, you know,
underneath the curtains and as we got into
the dive you'd see everything start to hover
and you'd hear like, 'Go, go, go, go, go!'"
[Laughter]
And the guy failed. I mean—
I mean, who wouldn't? If it were me, I mean,
my colon would be like, you know, sorry boss,
10am absolute latest I can do for you. So,
this is why at NASA Ames, there is an engineer
and part of his job was to design a very high
fidelity fecal simulant. So now, no poor guy
from Waste Management Systems has to go ride
the Vomit Comet, on the toilet, and try to
go in 22 seconds. So this is a very long-winded,
rambling way of saying that everything gets
simulated in the most entertaining ways. Let's
see, they also do--the psychological elements
of long duration space flight are a little
easier and cheaper to simulate. Basically
you put people in a box for a while and you
watch them and you see, give them difficult
stressful situations and you put in people
of different gender and culture and you see
how they don't get along and fist fights break
out and people claim sexual harassment so,
there are all kinds of these interesting psychological
simulations. It's a little difficult, as I
as a reporter, I like to go on scene and be
there, so I thought, well I'll apply. There
was one called Mars500, you might have heard
of, that is underway right now. And there
was a little three-month trial for Mars500
and there is something going on in Moscow.
A bunch of boxes underground floor of the
Institute for Biomedical Problems, which if
it were here it would be Institute of Biomedical
Solutions.
[Laughter]
But in Moscow, it's Problems. So, the Russian
Space Agency and the European Space Agency
we're gonna do this stimulation, Simulated
Mars Mission, and to work out the kinks, they
thought, OK, we'll do a three-month lead-up
just to see how everything goes and I thought,
well, that would be very interesting for the
book, so I applied and I got, as far as I
got. I passed the medical portion of it and
various sort of filling out the form, or whatever,
and they said, OK, you made it onto the next
stage, and I said, OK, great. They said, we'll
be calling you. So, some weeks went by and
the phone rings and it's 4 in the morning
and I don't really take care to hide my irritation,
that it's 4 in the morning and I picked it
up and "Hello," and "This is the European
Space Agency and we understand you've applied."
and "Don't you know what coast? I don't live
in Europe," you know, I was just the bitch
that I am, especially at 4 in the morning.
Well, that was part of the test. So I did
not get chosen--
[Laughter]
--to be part of the Mars500 lead-up. But anyway,
it's an interesting situation, the psychological--I
got called a bunch, when the Chilean miners
were underground. This is sort of an analogist
situation, they call it "isolation and confinement,"
and it does a very unique number on the human
psyche. You a, space is a really, it's a frustrating
place, because you're stuck in this room and
you can't, you really soaking in it. If something
is bothering you, you can't just run out,
slam the door and go for a drive. All the
things that you may do to relive stress, like
going for a jog, or having a drink, or a hot
bath, or shopping, whatever it is that you
do to relive stress you can't do that in space,
so you get this frustration that builds up
and up, and in a long mission it starts to
kind of metastasize to just anger and hostility
and psychologists will tell you, anger wants
an outlet, so if somebody is gonna get it.
You are gonna reach the breaking point and
get mad at someone. And in space you don't
want to get mad at your fellows crew members
because you depend on them for your survival,
you are only gonna make them mad or worse.
So what happens, and it's called "Displacement,"
and what happens, and you see it in the mission
transcripts, the astronauts would get really
irritable with Mission Control. And those
poor guys at Mission Control—people are
just like: "I can't do that because it's on
the other side of the capsule. You don't even
not where it is." It's really, you see, in
Gemini 7 there is this moment Captain Lovell,
again, for him it wasn't Mission Control,
it was the nutritionist, Dr. Chance. You're
reading along on the transcript and you'll
see lot of going; "A memo to Dr. Chance: chicken
a la king, serial number 645, cannot even
get material through neck of packaging!" And
then like a minute later, "Further memo to
Dr. Chance: Chicken a la king all over the
window at this time.--
[Laughter]
--At $300 a meal, I think you guys can do
better!" Just really. Just letting them have
it. Hopefully Dr. Chance was getting some
counseling, like don]t take it personally,
he's just feeling frustrated. So, yes, poor
Dr. Chance. Anyway, so, simulations. What
else was I going to tell you guys about?
I can do this with one hand [unscrewing bottle
cap]. The third thing you can do with your
anger. You don't take it out on Dr. Chance
or Mission Control people, you turn it inward,
then you get depression. That's the classic
way to create depression in an individual
is to have no real outlet for anger and frustration
and turn it inward, and this, you would see
in some of the Mir missions and longer IS
(International Space) Station missions. There
was some serious depression going on at some
of the astronauts and cosmonauts have been
more candid about in recent years. I've interviewed
a couple of cosmonauts who had spent six month
together on Mir. Yuri Romanenko and Aleksandr
Laveykin and I asked Laveykin about this.
I said. "Did you find it a very depressing
experience?" and he said, "Mary, there were
times when I wanted to hang myself but it's
weightlessness--"
[Laughter]
--but you can't." The cosmonauts are really.
Sometimes it was a little difficult to get
the kind of access I wanted or the kind of
candor that I wanted at NASA so I went all
the way to Star City, outside Moscow. And
these guys were great, I was gonna say, they
are so down to earth. That's not the best
term for an astronaut, cosmonaut, but we just
had really interesting conversations. You
could ask all the things that NASA, NASA they
were trying to be helpful in their way but
they just don't really like when people bring
up things like sex. But in Moscow, I remember
I said, you know, "You guys, six month, a
couple of guys in a can. You're young, healthy
men, was that kind of awkward? What do you
do with your sexual urges?" He said, "Mary,
everybody asks me this," and I said, "Sasha,"
that was his nickname, "Sasha, how are you
making sex in space?" and he says, "Of course,
by hand." [Laughter] And he said, "Why is
this an issue? Who cares?" So, anyway he was
a lovely and delightful person. I think I'll
read one little passage because it's kind
of fun and then maybe I'll open it up for
questions, because I don't know how much time
we have?
>>Unknown speaker: Plenty of time.
>>Mary Roach: OK. I'm going to read a short
section from the book, because it's kind of
a fun section.
So, this is Apollo 16 and we have Charlie
Duke and John Young who have been tooling
around on the moon, surface of the moon, collecting
rocks, doing their thing up there. And now
they are in a radio debriefing with Mission
Control. "Out of the blue," Young declares,
"I got the farts again. I got them again,
Charlie. I don't know what the hell gives
it to me. I think is acid in the stomach.
Following Apollo 15, in which low potassium
levels were blamed for heart arrhythmias of
the crew, NASA had put potassium-laced, orange,
grapefruit and other citrus drinks on the
menu.
"Tang. Young kept going, it's all there on
the mission transcript. I mean, I haven't
eatten this much citrus fruit in 20 years
and I'll tell you one thing, in another 12
fucking days I'm never eating anymore and
if they offer to serve me potassium with my
breakfast, I'm gonna throw up. I like an occasional
orange. I really do, but I'll be damned if
I'm gonna be buried in oranges." Moments later,
Mission Control comes on the line and provides
Young with yet more fodder for indigestion:
'Uh, Ryan, this is Houston.' 'Yes, sir.' 'OK.
You have a hot mike.'
[Laughter]
"'Oh. How long have we had that?'
"'That's been on through the de-briefing.'
The day after Young's comments hit the press,
the Governor of Florida issued a statement.
[Laughter]
"In defense of his state's key crop, Charlie
Duke paraphrases in his memoir. 'It is not
our orange juice which is causing the trouble;
it is an artificial substitute that does not
come from Florida.'
[Laughter]
"'Murphy,' oh, whoops, 'in fact it was the
potassium not the orange juice, the 'coefficient
of flatulence for orange juice,' to use the
terminology of USDA Flatus researcher, Edward
Murphy.
[Laughter]
"A panelist on the 1964 conference on Nutrition
in Space and related waste problems is low.
Murphy had reported on research he had done
using an experimental bean meal fed to volunteers,
who had been rigged by a rectal catheter,
to outgas into a measurement device. Murphy
was interested in individual differences,
not just in the overall volume of flatus,
but in the different percentages of constituent
gasses. Owing to differences in intestinal
bacteria, half the population produces no
methane. This makes them attractive as astronauts.
[Laughter]
"Not because it stinks, but because methane
is highly flammable. Murphy had a unique suggestion
for the NASA astronauts selection committee.
'This wasn't a joke, this paper; The astronaut
maybe selected from that part of population
producing little or no methane or hydrogen--
hydrogen also being explosive--and very low
levels of hydrogen sulfide and other malodorous
trace flatus constituents not yet identified.'
In other words, he was telling NASA: when
you choose your astronauts, make sure you
check their farts. And they did not. This
was never was part of the recommended astronaut
attributes that NASA adopted. But what they
did instead, is they became very careful in
certain foods were blacklisted. Cabbage, beans,
brussels sprouts and broccoli were actually
blacklisted. You could not serve them in space.
Beans came back during the shuttle era and
there were those who welcomed their arrival,
not just because they're tasty. The zero gravity
fart has been a popular orbital pursuit, particularly
on all male flights.
[Laughter]
"One here tells astronauts using intestinal
gas like rocket propellant to 'launch themselves
across the mid-deck.'
[Laughter]
"As astronaut Roger Crouch put it. Crouch
had heard the claims and was dubious. 'The
mass and velocity of the expelled gas,' he
told me in an email that forever after endeared
him to me, 'is very small compared to the
mass of the human body, therefore it is unlikely
that they could accelerate a 180-pound astronaut.'
Crouch pointed out that an exhaled breath
does not propel an astronaut in any direction
and the lungs hold 6 liters of air versus
the farts, which we have learned from Dr.
Murphy, hold at most, 3 soda cans worth. Or
the average person's, anyway. 'My genes,'
this is Crouch again, 'have blessed me with
an extraordinary ability to expel the byproducts
of digestion. So, given that, I thought that
it should be tested.'" I love this guy. He's
a retired astronaut, I should point out. There
is just no way as an active astronaut you
would ever have this conversation with somebody
active. OK, so "I thought it should be tested
and what I thought was a voluminous and rapidly
expel purge, I fail to move noticeably." So,
there you go.
[Laughter]
Yeah, we'll leave it at that. Anyway, I would
love to answer questions that you may have
about any of this stuff or any of my other
books, or my personal life or really just
anything at all, because we have little time.
Do we have a little time? If it brings up
something of interest I'll natter on in another
direction, but if anybody has anything that
love to ask about.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Maybe we could
just repeat the question.
>>Mary Roach: Yes. Sure, sure. Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #1: I remember reading
your column when [inaudible]. I wonder how
did that [inaudible]
>> Mary Roach: Sure. Wow, yeah, I wrote a
column for "Reader's Digest" years ago. It
was a little humor column, it had mostly to
do with my husband. He's a kind of an interesting
and entertaining individual. "Shush, the refrigerator"--what
was that one about, the refrigerator is listening?
>>Female Audience Member #1: It was about
[inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: Oh my God. I don't even remember.
I wrote a lot of those columns. I'm sure it
was really funny. Yes. Anyway, how did I get
from that, this was sort of a strange career
trajectory. I went from writing a funny column
for "Reader's Digest" to a book about cadavers.
And people would occasionally==fans of the
cadaver book would discover the Reader's Digest
column and vice versa, and go, "really?" But
I just--I had been wanting to work on a larger
project. The column was 700 words. I've been
wanting to come up with a book project. I've
been writing a column around that time also
for salon.com and there were been a couple
columns that had to do with some sort of interesting,
bizarre cadaver research. There were three
columns and a conversation with an agent grew
into a book proposal, wasn't lifelong fascination.
I never, I was not suckled by morticians,
meaning I had never read about cadavers before.
It just seemed that everything had been written
about before except cadavers, squirrels. It
was not much left out there. So, I said, Cadavers.
I'll do that one. So, that's how it happened.
There was no real logical flow from "Reader's
Digest" to dead bodies. Or not one that I've
been able to find. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #2.I'm really curious
about your thought process. As your writing
this sort of interesting combination of history,
personal interviews, science and humor. How
do you conceptually work your humor into this?
Is it humor first, science second, or ...?
Mary Roach: That's a great question. The question
is how do you work the humor into the science,
in the other material, in the other facets
of the book. Do you first start with the humor,
or do you like, inserted, injected afterwards?
I'm definitely, when I am choosing a topic,
I'm trying to find something that will provide
opportunities for fun, humor and surrealness
and quirkiness, so choosing the right topic
is really important. And I try as I go along
to work in the humor but frequently I feel
it's not funny enough, so I take another pass
and I'll look for opportunities to kind to
get a little goofier here and there. It's
a combination of up-front and shoehorning
some more of it in. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #3: So I love the footnotes
in your books
[Laughter]
>>Mary Roach: The footnotes. Yes. My favorite
part too.
>>Male Audience Member #3: [inaudible]...
the comment about anti-gravity [inaudible]
I was wondering how much research you leave
on the cutting room floor?
>>Mary Roach: The question has to do with
my footnotes. The footnotes are places where
I found something really spectacular, goofy
and fabulous and doesn't really naturally
fit the narrative and I can't bear to leave
it out, so I put it in a footnote. That's
why there is very little on my cutting room
floor. The anti-gravity stones? Technically
should be on the cutting room floor. They
have nothing to do with anything but I couldn't
resist the whole story of Roger Babson, the
man who wanted to defeat gravity and started
the Gravity Society who were very unfriendly
to me on the phone.
[Laughter]
>>Mary Roach: "We are neither pro, nor anti-gravity."
>> Mary Roach: OK. Good. But then I found
out, yeah, that he had donated money for these
stones, the anti-gravity stones, and Colby
College and a number of these colleges have
these stones up, because they gave a lot of
money. And the student body came to knocking
them over. It's like, ha, ha, gravity. Still
exists. And I that I think I worked some of
into the narrative. It's not all in the footnote.
It should be all in the footnote or on the
cutting room floor. Or I need to write a biography
of Roger Babson someday. Anyway, not much
on the cutting room, it's good it goes in
somehow or another. Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #2: Do you work on...
I noticed [inaudible] and I remember the scene
where cadavers are being pummeled while [inaudible]—
>>Mary Roach: Oh, the crash impact.
>>Female Audience Member #2: [inaudible] You
did a similar one impacting cars.
>>Mary Roach: Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #2: Do you [inaudible]
simultaneously? Do you go back to that place
[inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: Just let me know if you've got
a space cadaver. No, NASA's work with the
cadaver, which is in the new book, was going
on while I was working on that. It was just
sort of a fluke and I stumbled onto it and
I thought, "Got to have that in the book,"
because I always get mail from readers of
"Stiff" saying, "When are you gonna do another
book about cadavers?" or "Or the next one
is not about cadavers!" So, I thought, yes!
I can work cadavers into the space book, so
I worked my tail off to get access to that.
I mean, I heard about it. I forget where.
I said to NASA, "I wrote the book 'Stiff,'"
you know, cadavers are me. "I'd like to be
there." They were very uncomfortable with
this and kept saying, "No, the Constellation
Program says no, the headquarter people says
no." Finally the guy at Ohio State, where
they run the Crash Test Facility said: "Just
show up, just show up Mary and we'll deal
with it then." So it was a quite dramatic
morning with the NASA people running down
and telling the graduated students, "Don't
talk to her." It all worked out OK in the
end, but it was a little touch and go for
a while. But it was just a fluke, a cadaver
fluke. Interesting image. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #4: [inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: It would be very similar on
a Mars Mission. The question was in Apollo
and Gemini you got these two guys in a capsule
and not just the thousands of people at NASA
and Mission Control, et cetera, but everybody
on the planet watching. There are moments
of paranoia. I found, and I don't remember
which mission this was, I think it was Gemini
or Apollo. I wish I could remember which one,
but the astronauts start to hear this weird
signing sound. One of them goes: "Do you hear
that? It sounds like someone singing." And
the other guy goes, "Yes, that's really eerie."
And it goes on for a little while and one
of them said, "Should we tell them about it?"
"No. I don't think so."
[Laughter]
I don't know how they dealt with that but
I think that Mars Mission is like the animal
in the box that everybody is watching. I couldn't
do it. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #5: How is that situation
different from other confined places like
submarines and cave exploring?
>>Mary Roach: Yes. It's not that different.
In fact, they use submarines. They use Antarctic
field camps. They use these as analogs to
do research into isolation and confinement,
because Antarctica, while you are not confined
in a closed space, you are effectively confined
because you can't wander, go anywhere because
you will freeze and die in a whiteout. So,
you are stuck with the people that you are
with. And it's very, very similar. I don't
know psychologically, I don't know if there
is a unique--They talked about with Mars.
Sorry, the question was how similar is thse
analog situations to space. They talked about
one thing that would be different with the
Mars Mission, something called Earth Out of
View phenomenon. And it would be the first
time that astronauts, any human being, have
been so far from Earth that can no longer
really see it. And I asked Krikalev, Sergei,
I think is his first name, who is the head
of the astronaut training in Star City in
Moscow. I read him a description of how they
think once you can no longer see Earth, like
the moral structure of Earth will fall away
and people may kill each other and blah, blah,
blah. And I said, "What do you think about
this?" and he said, "I think that psychologists
need to write papers."
[Laughter]
>>Mary Roach: So, that's the main difference
that I hear kind of bandied about. But they
are very, very similar psychologically. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #6: Astronauts have
very competitive personalities. Did you see
different reactions because of that which
wasn't expected otherwise?
>>Mary Roach: Reactions to?
>>Male Audience Member #6: All the toll in
space.
>>Mary Roach: The question is, "Astronauts
have very competitive personalities and did
I see manifestations of that?" What's interesting
in aside, is they are competitive but the
personality of astronauts has change kind
of a 180 degrees from the Mercury and Gemini
and Apollo era, where you had a kind of aggressive,
macho, bravado, fearlessly going, large ego.
That's now the wrong stuff because you've
got much longer missions with five or six
people, so you kind of want a sensitive, new
age guy. You want someone with empathy. The
actual, some of the recommended astronaut
attributes are ability to form stable and
quality interpersonal relationships, sense
of humor, fairness, empathy, ability to tolerate
long stretches of tedium. So, they are still
aggressive, I mean, they still are competitive
because it is a very competitive, there is
not that many jobs open. So, they tend to
be, yes, competitive, but not kind of the
confrontational big ego types. They're really
easy going. Peggy Whitson, the commander on
ISS, when I was researching the book, she'd
be on NASA TV a lot and the example that I
tell people, to me sums up how you need to
be to be an astronaut. The guy from Mission
Control comes on and says, "Commander Whitson,
you took, you know the photos that you took
this morning? We can't find those anywhere."
If it was me, I would be like, so look again,
because I spent a long time on that and I
have a lot to do up here, I'm a little stress,
I didn't get any sleep, so–But she just
goes, "That's not a problem. We can do those
again." That's what they're like now. They're
not like Tom Wolfe's astronauts. Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #3: Can you talk
a little about [inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: Oh, I do know, I do know what's
next, but I don't have a file of fabulous
ideas waiting to be written. And I wish that
I did, because every time I work on a book
I think: "God, this is it; I never will come
up with another idea." It's kind of a process
of elimination. That says something else to
me now, since that chapter in the book. But
there are only so many topics that work, that
are gonna have some history, some science,
some fun, some color. I kind of know it when
I see it. Here is an example: "Bonk," the
sex lab book. There was absolutely a moment,
an exact moment where I knew, this is the
next book. I read a reference to, Masters
and Johnson had done--they were trying, Masters
and Johnson late '50s, were trying to document
the entire human sexual response cycle, and
for women some of that's interior, so they
were. "How we can do this?" "I know. We'll
make an acrylic phallus with a camera and
a light source and we'll have women have sex
with it." And this is the '50s, and I remember
me going, "Sex research, my next book. That's
it." I knew. I absolutely knew. So, sometimes
it's like that and other times it's kind of
like something I heard and how could I build
a book around that or is there something there.
And sometimes the germ of one book is in the
previous book. And I love ideas--maryroach.net,
send me ideas. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #7: I hate to say something
like NASA has that sub-special department
that [inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: Yes, I know those people.
[Laughter]
>>Male Audience Member #8: Are there stories
that you think are there that [inaudible]
that we would not like?
>>Mary Roach: Oh. Yes. There are millions
of one. I mean, NASA, the whole Space Program
is just delightfully surreal and ludicrous.
I mean, look what we're doing. We're putting
human beings up at this place where nothing
for them, where they don't belong. The engineering
challenges, the psychological challenges.
Plus it's a government organization. I would
love for somebody as an insider to write a
wonderful book about NASA. Mike Mullane, the
astronaut Mike Mullane did a book that was
pretty close to that. He really did. He was
very forthcoming about the whole culture at
NASA and what it's like. I recommend that
book as a sort of inside point of view. I
was an outsider, so I was struggling to get
whatever little scraps I can. But I had this
sense that, yes, untold fabulous stories out
there, waiting to be put into a book by somebody
who works there now. OK, one more question.
Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #9: Can you talk about
how people deal with boredom in space?
>>Mary Roach: The boredom in space? Yeah.
It's tough because there is not a lot recreational
opportunities. People bring musical instruments.
One of the Japanese astronauts brought a karaoke
machine, which I think could possibly have
created some interesting psychological tension.
[Laughter]
I'm sure that e-readers--The Kindle had not
been passed for outgassing testing yet. Everything
that flies out there get sent to this guy,
he's like NASA's nose, and he sniffs it and
do these tests for volatiles, to make sure
there is nothing harmful coming off. And the
Kindle had not yet been ytested, or any of
the other e-readers. There is reading, obviously,
but there is some time, particularly in the
long duration missions, there is not eight
hours a day of work to be done and the boredom
was apparently, was part of the reasons some
of the astronauts were very depressed. That
was the main contributing factor, was that
there was nothing to do and the scenery never
changes. What?
>>Female Audience Member #4: [inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: Yes. Anything that's portable.
They have a weight cut-off for how much personal
stuff you can bring, but you can bring up
games, guitars. People have brought up, so.
Certainly not a Ping-Pong table, for various
reasons, but--
[Laughter]
--maybe you'll figure out something up to
do with it different. Whatever you can bring,
Sudoku, like portable stuff. Kind of like
a camping trip or a backpacking trip, where
my husband and I always bring Travel Scrabble.
You bring something that's not going to put
you over the limit on your weight requirement.
Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #10: Were there jugglers
or any kind of circus performers [inaudible]?
>>Mary Roach: Were there jugglers or circus
performers? Someone brought a boomerang up
on either the shuttle or the ISS. I thought,
who allowed that? Like hurling things around
in a delicate machine. But interestingly enough
the boomerang flew OK. That doesn't make sense
to me. I don't know why, I don't just think
it will work. A juggler, that would be a challenge.
One more question. Yes.
Oh, you were juggling.
[Laughter]
>>Male Audience Member #10: [inaudible]
>>Mary Roach: I know. Yes.
>>Female Audience Member #5: Speaking of the
footnotes, how do you keep focus on those
wonderful archives? I could imagine ending
up being there for days.
>>Mary Roach: Yes, How I do keep focus on
those wonderful archives? The trick is not
keep focus, because when you get distracted
and you go off and you start flipping the
pages of some old back issue on some journal
you find the most amazing things. You may
find your next book in the pages. So I am
a big proponent of following your distractions.
I am not a terribly productive person in an
archive or elsewhere, but I do allow myself
the indulgence of going off on tangents. Thanks.
Thank you.
[Applause]